welcome to this video course on
minimalapi with.net 7. by the end of the
course you will be able to build
well-constructed minimal API endpoints
brugen Patel developed this course he is
an experienced and popular course
creator and developer let's get started
hi guys and welcome to dotnet Mastery my
name is brugen and I will be your
instructor for this course on minimal
API
API has been there since a very long
time but Microsoft has launched
something new with API which are minimal
API
if you are a dotnet developer your first
reaction would be why would I need
minimal API when I'm perfectly happy
with the standard API that are there
on top of that minimal API as the name
suggests offer less features as compared
to a traditional API
and in this course we will answer all of
those questions as we will explore all
the benefits minimal API brings to the
table
we have a lot to cover in this course
but there are some prerequisites that
you should know
so you should be able to follow along as
long as you have about three to six
months of experience with C sharp
that being said let me walk you through
on what we will cover in this course and
explore the new world of minimal API
let's take a look at what will be all
the topics that will be covered in this
course
first question that we will answer is
why minimal API what is the reason
behind the evolution does it bring any
benefits as compared to the API and what
is the different structure when it comes
to an API
once we enter that basic question we
will understand the basic fundamentals
of minimal apis what files are there and
what is different as compared to API
then we will be building endpoints with
our API and we will Implement custom
validations in minimal API
minimal API does not support the model
State validations that are there in API
so we will see how to validate some
things in minimal API
we will learn more about dependency
injection we will inject Auto mapper and
we will see how to map dtos in our
application
and then we will perform crud operation
with minimal API
so you can see there's a lot that we
have to cover let me get started with
all of that from the next video
the main question that comes around all
the developers
especially.net developers is why minimal
API we had a perfectly functional API
that has been there and we love that
with the controllers attributes and all
the features that are built in
if that is working perfectly why is
Microsoft taking some bits and pieces
out of that API and giving us a very
empty template which is something like a
minimal API
what could be the benefits of having a
to answer that let us consider the
scenario if a developer is coming from a
non.net background for example node.js
in that case they might not be aware of
what is a controller what are naming
conventions for controller and learning
all of that would require some
understanding of.net but their main
focus is to get the API up and running
quickly without learning all the
fundamentals of dotnet programming
that is one of the reason behind
development of minimal API we want to
have the minimal code that is needed for
API rather than adding controllers
because if you think about that when we
have to build an API in other
programming languages or even in.net
controller is not something that is
always needed it has been there because
previously we had MVC and we had
controllers so Microsoft thought about
unifying both of them and that is the
idea behind controllers
with minimal apis we do not have the
controller we keep everything simple and
straightforward in a class file now when
we learn minimal API everything will
typically be in a program.cs class file
but then developers might think that my
code will look ugly if I have 50
endpoints and all of them are in one
file do not worry we can of course
separate them out in different files as
well but main point here is we don't
need a controller
now since we are not adding extra
features like controllers and other
overhead which is not always needed for
an API we gain performance Improvement
which takes higher priority in some
situations
so if we are keeping things minimal then
the performance of our API will increase
Microsoft is investing time in minimal
API and it is adding more and more
features
like previously there were no filters
but they have added filters with minimal
API in.net 7 and much more
with all the new features being added
minimal API are gaining more and more
attention especially in scenarios like
microservices where API are not that
intensive and efficiency plays a
critical role with that overview I'm
sure you are excited to learn minimal
API and what they have to offer what is
the syntax how we can perform crud
endpoints and much more
to get started we need to create a
project that will use minimal API
so I will open Visual Studio 2022 and we
will hit create a new project
in the templates here we will search for
the regular API project and we have the
asp.net core web API using C sharp
let me hit the next button here and we
need to give project name
project name I will change that to be
magic Villa underscore coupon API we
will change the location where we want
to save the project and the solution
name I will call that minimal API demo
looks good let me add that and we have
more option
the framework here we will be using
dotnet 7
authentication type we will keep that as
none but later on in the course we will
be adding authentication and
authorization
configure for https looks good we do not
want the docker support but the main
thing here is use controllers we have to
uncheck that if we want to use minimal
API
because if you keep this check then it
will create the regular API project with
controllers we do not want that so we
will uncheck that and that will create a
minimal API
we will enable the open API support and
lastly we do not want to use the top
level statements we can keep that as
unchecked
with that in place let me hit the create
button with the default settings
and create our project is created here
and we have our minimal API right here
before we go through the files that we
have in minimal API here let me create a
regular API project that way we can
compare and see what is different
so in the solution here we will add a
new project
and it will be an API project
I will call that regular API sample let
me add that we want to use the
controller so make sure that that is
checked and we will hit the create
button
perfect that is created
now that we have a minimal API and a
regular API project let me compare to
see what is different
you can see in minimal API project we
have properties folder same thing is
there in regular API and there it is
just the launch settings.json file that
basically tells that which Port it
should use and it has a profile for
Castrol as well that stays the same
because no matter if it's a minimal API
or a regular API it still needs to run
the project on a URL
then outside of properties folder we
have app settings.json that is also
constant in both of the files
but other than that in minimal API there
is just one file which is program.cs
whereas in the regular API we have
controllers we have program.cs and the
weather forecast model class as well
so going by the name minimal API has
actually minimal file only program.cs
and that file has all the logic
now let me set the startup project as
both of the project here
and let's see if the output is any
different
yeah
and great we have both of them up and
running here let me add them side by
side
and perfect we have both of them right
here we have the regular API and here we
have the minimal API
from the login field you can see both of
them looks the same we have one endpoint
weather forecast that looks good in the
Swagger documentation we try that
and execute everything is the same we
have the same response and everything
looks the same so from the look and feel
or the functionality wise minimal API is
not that different now of course as we
proceed with the course there will be
some features that are not yet available
in minimal apis or they are not planned
to be added but the base functionality
that we can see right out of the box
looks the same but minimal API has only
one file the regular API has controllers
program.cs and weather forecast
so that gives you a good comparison
between the files that are present in
minimal API as compared to the regular
API project
now as a prerequisite to this course I
hope that you have a basic thread
functionalities of what API is
responsible for if not I have a free
course on YouTube that you can take to
get familiar
but here in the regular API we have a
controller endpoint we have the API
controller and we have the HTTP get
action method that will be the end point
which will be invoked
and here we have this model weather
forecast that is right here included
that is the regular API for you but now
let me open the only file that is
present in the minimal API which is
program.cs
now if I switch the files here you will
notice that add controllers is not
present in program.cs of the minimal API
and that makes sense because in minimal
API we do not have any controllers
then the Swagger endpoints they are
present because we want the Swagger
documentation with our minimal API as
well
after that we have app.build and that is
the same
where we are configuring the pipeline we
have Survivor documentation for
development we have https redirect
authorization map controllers and run
but in program.cs we don't have much
things we have Swagger we have the https
redirect and that's about it we just
have the app.run after that so we do not
have any authorization or map
controllers that are added by default
the main idea behind minimal API is to
keep things super simple if you have the
requirement to add those you can of
course add them like in a minimal API
project it is of course possible to add
a regular API with controllers if you
want that but that is not the main
purpose of a minimal API it is there to
keep things super simple
so if I examine the program.cs we just
have app.run with https redirect and
Swagger in the request pipeline
now the main question is how will it
work
before we check that let me remove the
regular API project that we added I only
added that to compare the differences so
you get an idea we don't need that
anymore
with that we only have one file here
which is program.ces open and that looks
good let's continue from the next video
when we run the project here we notice
that that is one endpoint which is
weather forecast but where is this
endpoint we do not have any controllers
or any other file so basically that
endpoint will be somewhere in program.cs
if you scroll down here we have the map
get right here
that endpoint is mapping a get request
and we have the route right here
when we expand that you can see there is
a little code right here and this
defines what needs to be returned back
when this endpoint is called with an
HTTP get request
we also have with name and with open API
that we will come back to later on
but basically this is how mapping is
done and if any model classes are needed
in the default template they are added
right here this is a record and we have
the summaries array right here
so all the calculation on what should be
returned when the endpoint is invoked is
right here in the program.ces course
file
now that will bring up lots of question
if you are coming from a regular API
background and do not worry we will
answer them one by one
but in order to get started let me
remove all the code that is added here
for the endpoint we want to start clean
here
so perfect now what program dot CS only
has the Swagger endpoints here pipeline
also has the Swagger UI https redirect
and that's it no controllers no
authorization nothing else is present in
our project or pipeline right now
let me run the project we should not see
the end point that was there before and
we see no operations defined in the spec
so we do not have any endpoints in our
API and everything is clean right now
let's continue and add our first
endpoint in the next video
the next section that I have is all
about the API Basics like what is a
request what is a response what are HTTP
verbs and so on
now these are the fundamentals of API
and it does not matter whether it's an
API a minimal API
so if you are aware of the basic
fundamentals like post put patch delete
and what is a request response with the
API feel free to skip this section and
move on to the next section where we
will start the programming but if you
want a refresher let's do that from the
next video
we have the big question on what is an
API
the definition for an API is application
programming interface but that is not
explanatory
in simple words API is responsible for
transmitting the data
or rather it is a way for multiple
applications to communicate with each
other
in today's technology driven world we
are connected like never before
API is the critical engine behind
sharing information across multiple
application
in programming API is responsible for
getting a request from the client and
then sending a response back to the
client based on the request
and the request and response there will
be multiple of them and it continues
so basically if a client is looking for
some data it would ask API by sending a
request and then API would return back
that data in form of a response
the model that we see here is the
website model what is different between
that and an API
what makes an API stand out is it is not
just the web browser that can call an
API many other application can invoke an
API endpoint
so let's say you have an API that can be
consumed by a web application your
mobile application your Windows
application and much more not only that
you can expose your API to other clients
and we have more examples of that
but before we go into those details the
example that we see here is related to
programming let me simplify that by
going to a real world scenario
let's say we go to a restaurant and we
have menu on the table and after a lot
of thinking we finalize on what to order
Chef is also ready to start cooking
but the missing link here is to tell
Chef on what we want
that is where server comes into the
picture which is basically like an API
server will be responsible for taking
order from the table and telling Chef on
what needs to be prepared
and that would basically resemble a
request
once the food is ready then server will
pick that food and deliver that back to
the table which will be a response
so here you can see how server is acting
like an API where it is taking the
request and then it is delivering back
the response from our kitchen
now let me show you one real world
scenario which many of you would have
experienced without realizing that it is
driven by API let's imagine we are going
on a vacation and we need to book
tickets and hotel reservation
like myself I'm sure you want the best
deal out there but it will be a huge pin
to go to Every Airline website to see
what is the price of that ticket for a
specific date
rather than that you would prefer going
to a website like kayak.com Expedia or
Priceline where they will display the
rates for multiple Airlines and you can
filter the best deal from their website
what happens in the back end on
kayak.com is American United and spirit
would have exposed an API
kayak.com will be calling those API
endpoints based on date origin and
destination and it will return all the
response from the individual website
whatever response it returns from those
website it will display on kayak.com
so basically American United spirit and
other airlines would have their own API
and kayak will be calling those API
endpoints to display the connected
information in one place
same thing happens when you compare
hotel rates on Expedia Priceline or
other websites where they get
information from multiple websites
so as you can see API is the main
superhero between connected services
in today's world we take the web for
granted when we open a browser and we go
to a web page we just expect it to open
up and work that is the default Behavior
but what goes under the cover is a black
box
in reality many things happen between
when you search for something on the
browser and what you see on the screen
once you hit an enter button
let's talk about what happens when we
make such a request we will consider an
API in our scenario
for example when we go on a laptop and
search for something on google.com or
any other web page
it is going to make a request to some
remote server
now this request is actually a text
document
so basically it will send a text
document to Google server and this
document will contain three information
first it will have a verb which defines
what is the action that server has to
take
then we have headers which have
information about the request itself and
finally we have content which is an
optional field
as an example let's say you want to
create something on the server
so in that case the HTTP verb will be
post and we will learn about this verbs
in just a minute but when we have to
create we will be using post and that is
what we have in HTTP verb
inside header we might have information
about the content length that the
content here will be 9 byte and finally
we are sending magic API as the content
let's say that is a string that we want
to create
so all the data will be inside the
content
now this is just an example but this
gives you a brief idea of what will be
there in the text document
when the server gets this request it can
either recognize that as something it
can process or it might reject it
because something might not be valid
with the request
but in both the cases it will send a
response back to the client
and in that response we will have three
items again
we will have a status code header and
content
when client makes a request server
processes that and sends back a response
response is also a piece of data
you can think about that as another text
document
the status code here basically defines
the request that was made was it
successful did it fail based on the
different failed scenarios or successful
scenarios we have different status code
in our example we did HTTP post a
request so it might send a status code
of 201 which stands for created
we will get to know the status code very
soon so do not worry right now it says
201 created in the response status code
which means I have created the resource
that you have asked me to and I'm going
to return you some data along with that
certain content type we are saying that
the data that I'm sending back is of
type text and then in the actual content
let's say the server is sending back
magic API
one important thing that you have to
remember is server itself here is
stateless
stateless basically means that server
will not remember things and what I mean
by that is server will be getting
multiple requests once it processes that
request and sends a response back it
forgets about that request
because if it was remembering about all
the requests then you can just imagine
on how massive the memory consumption
will be and the disk will be overloaded
with the data of all the requests that
it received
so always remember that server will be
stateless
based on what we have seen we have a
request that is originated from the
client and we have a response the
request will have verb header and
content and response will have status
code headers and content
in the next video let me dive a little
bit more into what exactly is in request
what is HTTP verb headers content and
similarly in response what a status code
headers and content
let me do that in the next video
let's understand the request object that
we have
first thing in the request object is
verb and these are HTTP verbs or action
they basically Define what is the action
that needs to happen
if you are working with some data you
might want to create read update or
delete that data we have specific verb
which defines what action is needed for
the request
most common of the HTTP verb is when you
want to fetch some resource or a web
page
which basically means that hey get me
something from the server
so cat basically means fetching some
data and that is most common
after that we have post which is used to
create or insert a new resource
whenever you want to add a new record or
anything on the server you will be using
the post request
then we have put which is used to update
a resource that already exists on the
server
sometimes we also use patch which
basically means that please do not
update the whole resource I only want to
update a part of that resource
for example if your object has 100
properties and you only want to update
one of those properties you will use
patch in that case
put basically contains the complete
resource and Patch works on one part of
the resource
then we have delete which is pretty
obvious it basically deletes the
resource from the server
there are more HTTP verbs but they are
very rarely used and typically we always
play with the five that are most common
so that gives you a brief idea of HTTP
verb and what action they are
responsible for
next part in the request object is the
header
headers are a set of name value pair
that are metadata about the request
first one you can see is the content
type
that basically answers the question on
what is the content type of the request
is it a binary data is it a Json file is
it an XML file or is it a plain file
then we have content length which
basically defines the size of the
content
and request metadata you might also have
authorization
sometimes a request needs to be
authenticated in that case the
authorization header will be populated
with a better token or whatever
authentication you are using
we also have accept type which defines
what kind of a request is acceptable
like Json XML and so on
and then there are literally hundreds of
headers you can also Define your own
headers if they are helpful in your
situation
but headers basically have metadata of
the content and request
and finally we have content
content is an optional field here we can
pass the content that the server will
require to complete the request it can
be a Json object which can later be
deserialized by the server to process
the request
it can also be blobs that have to be
created or updated
if you are trying to retrieve a resource
then you will be using HTTP get verb and
get will never have the body because we
are requesting the API to return
something and the API does not expect
any data in the request
but if you are posting or updating then
we might have to pass the object that
needs to be updated or created
that way the API can extract that object
from the content and process the request
this is a brief overview of the request
object
that being said let's analyze the
response that we get from the API in the
next video
in the last video we saw the request
object which had verb headers and
content
now let's examine the response object
which is basically once the request is
received by the server or API it will
process that it might be accepted it
might be rejected failure or success
whatever it is it will return back a
response
the first thing that we have in response
here is the status code
status code is simply a number that
represents on what was done on the
server and its final result
but all the numbers that are returned
have been arranged in some brackets and
they are very critical
like 100 to 199 are informational
you will rarely see the 100 status code
but they do exist
most common one that you will see is 200
to 299
any status code in that range basically
means that the request was completed
successfully
200 is most common which says everything
is okay and everything is done as
requested then next we have to go one
which means created
if you are posting something then you
can return it to someone that the
resource was created on the server that
defines 201
then we also have 204 no content
this is more common when we are updating
something because when we update a
record we just want the user or client
to know that the update was successful
and we do not want to pass the updated
record in that case we will return 204
which basically means no content but as
you can see it is within the success
bracket that means everything was
successful but we do not have any
content to return
next bracket is 300 to 399 which are
typically used when there is redirection
involved
after that we have 400 to 499 which
relates to client errors
what I mean by client edit means that
there is a error in the request that was
sent
you may not have included a query string
or some part of the URI does not exist
the famous one that you would have seen
on websites is 404
which represents not found
so let's say you are accessing an
endpoint that does not exist like let's
say you want to retrieve something based
on an ID but that ID does not exist
in that case API might return back 404
that the resource that you are looking
for does not exist
we have 400 status code which stands for
bad request which means something in the
request was not as expected
and then finally we have status code
within the bracket of 500 to 599 and
these are for internal server error like
the 500 here is internal server error
which means that errors have been
encountered on the server while
processing so basically the request that
was sent to the server was a valid
request but when that request was being
processed by a server let's say an
exception was thrown internally and
because of that the server could not
process a valid request
so at that time it will send a 500 which
means there was some error on the server
side and nothing was wrong in the
request
you can see status code plays a very
important role in the response object
because based on the status code the
client will be able to know if the
request was successful if it failed and
if it failed what was the reasons so on
then next we have headers in the
response object as well and they contain
metadata but this time they will have
metadata about the response object like
what is the content type what is the
length of the response content until
when it will be valid and so on
also similar to the request object we
have content in the response object as
well and that might contain Json result
it might contain blobs HTML whatever the
response server has to send that will be
in content
so typically if we have to compare
request and response both of them will
have headers and content but the main
thing that differentiates them here is
the verb and status code request has the
verb which defines what action needs to
happen and response has the status code
which defines if the request was
processed successfully if there were
errors and so on
headers will be different for request
and response but typically headers
Define metadata and content will have
any content that needs to be passed with
either request or response
so I hope this gives you a 10 000 feet
overview about request and response and
what is included in them
that being said let's continue from the
next video
now we know the basics about HTTP verb
but let's take a look at some URL and
get some theoretical idea behind the
HTTP verbs
most common HTTP verb is a cat request
let's assume we have a table where we
have list of all the coupons in our
website
that table is pretty simple it will just
have something like a coupon name what
discount we get and some other details
but we want an API endpoint if someone
calls that it should retrieve all the
coupons and send it back
now this is more like a read request
because of that the HTTP verb will be
get and then we have the API path
localhost 7001 whatever your domain is
that's okay
but after that let's assume we are
giving that a route of API and then
coupon
we do not have any other parameter here
and this basically the action we want is
to get all the coupons
so in the request party we will not pass
anything here but in the response that
we will get from the API it will give us
a list of all the coupons from our
database
so that is a get request
now another type of cat request is where
we are passing an ID of the coupon at
that point the HTTP verb is still get
but because there is an ID here we know
that the user only wants one coupon
request will not have any body but the
response party will have the single
coupon that user wanted
now of course if the ID is invalid we
will not send any response body with the
coupon but if that is valid the response
body will have a coupon
these two are basic requests in HTTP CAD
but let's say if a user or admin wants
to create a new coupon code
in that case our HTTP verb or the
request will be post and we will use the
same URL
now the way it will differentiate
between the first URL and this one is
the HTTP verb will be different if the
verb is pushed the API will know that
that means that we will be creating a
coupon
so API automatically differentiates
between the verb even if the URL are
same
so for post we will create a coupon and
when we are creating a coupon if someone
sends a request we obviously need the
details about that coupon
like on the website someone will write
the coupon name what is the discount
they want and then the admin will hit
the create button at that point in the
request we will get all the coupon
details that the API has to create
so API will create that coupon when it
receives the request and in the response
it could send the created coupon or a
route to that created coupon
now if everything here does not make
sense right now do not worry I am just
giving you a basic idea of API and its
action
next action on HTTP verb that we have is
put and that is to update any existing
coupon
in the route here when we are updating
we can pass the ID of the coupon that we
want to update
because of the HTTP put verb in request
we will require the coupon details that
have to be updated
and once the API updates the coupon it
typically does not send any response
like the updated coupon
if you want however you can send it but
that is not the typical route that is
taken
and finally we have the delete HTTP verb
where again we will pass the ID here
action we just need to delete that
coupon it does not have any request body
or a response based on the ID that is
there in the parameter it will delete
that coupon and return an OK request
that means everything was completed
successfully
so what we have seen here is what will
be in the request body or what we will
get in response based on the HTTP verb
and something in the URL whether we
require an ID if we don't need it and so
on
so this should give you a brief idea
about what each request or rather HTTP
verb is responsible for
now again this is just error of idea
once we start programming everything
will start making much more sense
that being said let me continue from the
next video
let me add our first endpoint right here
one thing that you should remember is
all the end points we will have to
configure that before the pipeline ends
because in a traditional API project if
you remember we were using something
like app.add controller and that was
adding controller to the pipeline here
we are not adding the controller so all
the endpoints of your API that you want
to add you will have to add that before
app.run
right here we will say app.map and you
saw before we had something called as
mapcat
that actually Maps or rather tells that
this will be an HTTP get action method
if you examine the parameters here we
have string with a pattern and a
delegate Handler
patent defines the route of this API
so we can say something called as hello
world and what should that return
you can keep it simple and we can just
return back hello word like that
that will add an end point in our
minimal API let me run the project
perfect you can see we have that route
here we can try that out execute that
and we have hello world
if you want to test that using sweater
or it is an HTTP CAD we can directly
paste that and we see the world right
here
perfect you can see our endpoint is
working as expected and how simple it
was to add an HTTP get and point right
here
now that would make you curious and now
you will be like can I have an HTTP post
endpoint of course you can we just have
map post here we can call this hello
world 2 and we can return hello world 2.
now typically in HTTP CAD you will have
something in from body where you will be
creating a record but we are keeping
things super simple right now
let me run this and see if that works
perfect we have the post here try that
out we don't need any parameters and
perfect we get the response
that looks great if it was an API
project there is no way that you can add
one line and the end point will be added
there
but here it is pretty simple
similar to mapcat we have map put and
map delete
so that way if we add app dot map here
and we scroll down we have to delete we
have the badge post put and where is the
get right here
so you can see we have all of those
basic methods for the API endpoint
with that in place let me continue from
the next video
right now we are adding or returning
what we have in a single line but what
if you have a complex calculation that
your API needs to handle and you need
multiple lines for that
that is simple as well
we will remove this and we will add a
curly bracket here we can perform all
the calculations right here
but to keep things simple we will just
return hello world right now
perfect this will work exactly the same
let me run that
and show that
try that out perfect that looks good
now right now you can see it returns a
200 okay
that is the response that we are getting
from the server but let's say there are
some errors here and we are returning an
exception here
but that time also it will return a 200
okay
right now there is no way to tell that
hey this is a bad request or something
went wrong on the server
so basically we have no way of
controlling what is the return type for
our API right now
that is also done everything that we
want to return inside results Dot and we
have the endpoints for the status code
we have accepted created not found at
request and all of that right here
let's say we have a bad request here and
inside there we are saying that there is
some exception that is being thrown
let me run that
we will try this here
and perfect now you can see our API is
returning a 400 which stands for pad
request
if everything was good right here we can
directly return results dot ok
inside there we will pass the hello
world if we want to keep that in same
line if we want multiple line you can
add the curly brackets and do the same
thing with results dot ok
let me run this and make sure that works
we are in closed here examine the
response that is 200 okay
so perfect with that let's continue from
the next video
the return results here we can toggle on
whether it is a good request or bad
request
but in an API endpoint sometimes we have
to pass something to the parameters
that might be a front body or let's say
an integer or a string parameter to
parse some data
when we have to use an integer typically
in an API we have to write the integer
name here let that be an ID
that stays the same but right here we
will see that we are expecting an
integer ID and we don't want exception
we will say OK here
and we can print the ID
and if I just say plus here
let me run that
perfect you can see it expects an ID so
either UI is displaying that let me
enter 11 and execute perfect we have the
correct response if you enter a string
here Swagger will display the error
message it has to be an integer but we
can open Postman here paste that URL and
see what happens
we see the exception here failed to bind
the parameter integer ID from this and
you can see the response type is 400 bad
request but if we are passing a string
then this should actually be a 404 not
found because the get endpoint that we
have is the end point with an integer
and not a string
how do we fix that
fixing that is super simple let me go
back to the map get here if we go back
here and we explicitly say that this ID
will be an integer only
that should solve our problem
let me go back to the postman and let me
execute
and perfect this time we have the 404
not found and that looks good
so we can be explicit with the
parameters similar to what we had in the
API project as well
we have seen some basic examples of
adding the end points but let me work on
something that is close to a real world
application
let's say we want to perform crud
operations on a model and that will be
coupons
so first we need to create a model for
that
insert solution we will create a new
folder and that will be models
in there we will right click add a class
file so I will call that as coupon
and inside there I will create six
properties we will have ID of the coupon
we will have the coupon name what
percentage discount will that coupon
give and if that coupon is active or not
I will also add another level created
and last updated
now if you are new to.net 6 and if we
examine the project here edit project
file you can see the label is enabled by
default
this basically means that if something
is null you have to explicitly Define
that property will be no
but to make things simple or if you are
working with a legacy.net application or
dotnet core project that is an older
version this must be disabled even if
you upgrade that because many times
personally I have seen when I have
upgraded the project to latest versions
of dotnet core and if this nullable is
enabled API endpoints are breaking
because previously we did not explicitly
Define every endpoint that it is a
nullable endpoint but now if that is not
defined it does not find that endpoint
so to be safe you can disable the
nullable in the Cs Branch file
like right here we have explicit laser
that created and last updated is
nullable so we should be good but to
avoid any issues or confusion we have
disabled the nullable flag inside the
project file
so our class here looks good next we
need to create a store that will have a
list of coupon
now down the road are typically in a
real world project you don't have a
store you have a database where you
manage or update all the coupons
but to keep things simple for now we
will add a coupon store
let me create a new folder which will be
data folder so
and in there we will add a class which
will be coupon store
inside there we will add a static
property which will be coupon list that
will be list of coupon and we have just
added two coupons in there
we will make this a static class as well
that way we do not have to create object
every time
perfect so our coupon store can now be
accessed with our new API endpoints that
we will create in the next video
now that we have coupon store and coupon
model it is time to add the first
endpoint that will retrieve all the
coupon
so we will say app.map get endpoint and
the route here rather than calling it
coupon I typically like to add API in
front of that so we will say forward
slash API and then coupon
that will retrieve all the coupons
we will be using the delegate here and
what it should return is results dot OK
and inside there we have to access the
coupon store that we created
I will add the using statement and in
there we have the coupon list that is
what we need to return
with that in place let me run the
project
perfect let me try this out here and
great we can see both the coupons in our
coupon store
now right now even though we have one
line here let me add a curly bracket
here and break this out
Google
right here we will add a return
statement
and we are missing the closing semicolon
perfect we have the multi-line function
right here
great so our get endpoint looks good let
me continue from the next video
we have the end point to get all the
coupons but what about when we have to
retrieve an individual coupon based on
the ID
we can create that as well
we know how to retrieve the ID so right
here
we will expect an ID and that will be
integer
we will have the same name here integer
ID and then when we are returning back
the result here from the coupon list we
can use first.default to retrieve the
record based on the ID
so U dot ID is equal equal to the ID
perfect let me run the project
we have ID 1 and id2 let me try the id2
here
and great we get the 20 off
so our coupon store is working as
expected we have two IDs and that
retrieval is working
next what we want is post put and delete
action endpoints
so let me just add them for now we need
the post here to create a coupon and
when we post we will use the same path
API forward slash coupon
now of course when we Post in the
Handler here we will receive a different
object
but we will worry about that later on
let me copy this
and paste it two more times here
light map post we have map put here and
we have the map delete
now in post and put both of them we will
receive the coupon object and the
parameters that way we can create or
edit the coupon but when we delete here
we will receive ID so let me copy that
and we will get the ID right here
perfect so these three looks good in the
next video let me first work on creating
a coupon
now we want to create a coupon
when we create a coupon we typically
receive a coupon object from the party
so getting that is exactly same like we
do in API project we will say from party
in the parameter here and we will
receive a coupon object let me call that
coupon
and we will add using statement for our
model
now from body requires a using statement
which is in microsoft.asp.cover.mvc
but once we add that it will know that a
coupon object will be passed from body
when the post request will be called
then before we create we typically have
some validation
we will add a validation here that if
the coupon ID is not 0 or if the coupon
name is empty that is an invalid ID or
coupon name because when we are creating
the coupon ID must be zero if it is
something else then that is not a valid
ID because ID is something that
typically the database or the code is
responsible for adding
but we don't have any database right now
so now we need to populate the ID
how will we do that we will keep things
manual we will say coupon dot ID is
equal to inside our coupon store we have
the list that let me order by descending
so we will get the maximum ID at the top
here U goes to U dot ID
and on there we will retrieve the first
record there we will retrieve the ID of
that record so here we are getting the
maximum ID of all the records that we
have in our coupon store
so that will be 2 right here
on that too we will add one
that means that we are manually setting
the ID plus 1 by the maximum ID in our
coupon store
and before I add the ID here I want one
more validation I do not want the same
coupon to be created again
so we can add an if condition in our
coupon store and try to retrieve first
or default based on the name that is
being created in the coupon I will use
the two lowercase that way we will make
coupon is insensitive
so if the code already exists we return
that result coupon name already exist
pretty good next we have the ID here
and then we have to add it to our coupon
store dot coupon list dot add we will be
adding coupon
perfect our create or post is complete
here once we do that we can return back
results
dot OK and there we can return coupon
that has been created
perfect let me run and see this in
action
only parameter that we have to change
here is name let me call that 30 off and
it is a 30 discount ID we can leave that
as 0 because if we go back to our
application we are changing that ID
based on the ID that we have in our
coupon store the maximum one is due so
next one will have the ID of three
the ID here we can remove that and it
will still work because it will
automatically populate the ID let me
remove that and hit the execute button
we scroll down and perfect in the
response body you can see ids3
if we go back and we try to get all here
now we have three coupons
but again this is a temporary data store
when you restart the application your
coupon store will be back to the first
two which are the defaults that we have
so keep that in mind we are not storing
this in database it is temporary and in
memory
so perfect our post is working as
expected
let me continue from the next video
before I work on put or delete when we
have the post here there are quite a few
things that are missing in our API
endpoint that we typically do in a.net
core API
one thing is rather than returning an OK
in HTTP post sometimes we return the
created add route now of course we can
return the created and that is
completely okay before that let me show
you how to use the results dot created
when we use created we have to write the
route where this is created and then for
the value we can pass coupon
so the URL here let me use string
interpolation here it's API forward
slash coupon and there we need the ID
will be inside coupon dot ID
and let me run that
we will create a new coupon we will
update the name and percent and let's go
down that is created here we have 201
and in the location we have API coupon
and three
let me go to the localhost URL here we
will add localhost and then we will
paste the route that we copied and great
that retrieves the appropriate coupon
with the correct name and percent
so created is working as expected
but what if we want to use the created
ad route
for that we actually have to give this
get some route name
how to do that
with minimal API after the map Gap here
we have something called as with name
and there we can provide name of this
endpoint
so right here I can call this endpoint
as get coupon and then we can use that
name
the first one here let me call that as
cat coupons
the HTTP post we will call that as
create coupon
then rather than using created let me
copy this comment it out and we will be
using created at route
inside there we need the route name as
the first parameter that is get coupon
next parameter here is the ID so we will
create a new object
and we will say ID is equal to
groupon.it and finally we will pass the
object
that looks good let me see if that works
we will post again
it will create an ID3
let me try that
and perfect that looks good here in the
location we have the complete URL as
well as the endpoint
if you copy that and try that
it should work
perfect so with that we know how to use
the width name to give our endpoints a
name and then we can use that in
something like created at route
now we have the names for our endpoint
but if I run the project here and if I
look at the Swagger documentation for
HTTP post here the response type here it
says that it will only return a 200 okay
but that is not correct
if we go back here if the ID is not zero
let me try that here so we will keep ID
as 3 execute this
we get a 400. so basically our endpoint
can return a 400 bad request
but in the available responses in the
Swagger UI it only thinks that it will
return a 200 okay
and that is because in a traditional API
application we have the HTTP response
and we explicitly say that these are the
possible status codes that are endpoint
can't return
how can we Define that with minimal API
for that on the map post here where we
have the width name we also have
something called as produces
and here we have generic where we can
say the model that will be produced
we know we are creating a coupon here so
I can say produces a coupon and then
what will be the status code
if everything is successful that will be
we also have a bad request here so we
will add producers and when it is a bad
request we do not have any model so we
will just add a producers 400 bad
request
if you have other status code you can
also add them right here
let me copy this and we will modify our
individual kit and get on
now this one will produce a 200 okay it
does not produce bad request
so let me remove that and 200 the first
one here will not be a coupon it will be
an i enumerable off coupon
perfect let me restart the application
right here you can see we have an array
when we have the individual get we do
not have the square bracket but let me
open the post here and there we have 201
we have the correct model and 400 bad
request we do not have any model in that
so that way we can explicitly Define
what will be the response that will be
produced
on top of that you can be explicit on
what this endpoint will accept
right here it is expecting a coupon so
where we have the width name we can also
say dot accepts that expects a coupon
and there you can explicitly write the
content type like if you want to limit
application Json you can say that
explicitly right here
with that let me run the project once
again
we go to post here and everything stays
the same because we had the request body
but that is more documented and now the
Swagger can read what are the exact
things that it expects what it produces
and the models as well
so perfect with that are three endpoints
that we have I believe we have good
documentation so far let me continue
from the next video
when you work with a.net core
application dependency injection is a
very critical piece and minimal API
supports that so don't panic
the first example that we will see is
the built-in eye logger that comes with
an API project
to see that in action let me create an
API project because I removed the one
that we have here we will create a
sample that's okay we don't care about
anything else here
and perfect here if we open our
controller you will notice we have an
eye logger on there we can use to lock
something in the console window
this eye logger is being used with
dependency injection and it is available
by default
so how can we use that in our minimal
API project
let me log something when we are getting
all the coupons right here
in the parameter here we can explicitly
say that we need an eye Locker
so if I go back to the API project let
me copy what we were passing in the
Constructor here
we do not need to create a private read
only we can directly retrieve that in
parameter like that
you can see I logger is being detected
but it does not detect the weather
forecast controller
but right now we are in program class
here so we can say that right here
and with that the logger has been
injected I like to use underscore for
all the dependency injection that we
have
we will add underscore logger on there
we have the log method log level we will
say information and we will say getting
all coupons
let me run the application and see if
that works
we are using cash flow to run the
application so when you run the project
you will actually have a command line
window like this that is open make sure
to open that
if you do not have that and if you are
using IIs Express to run that you can
also go to the output window and we have
debug here let me pin that as well
perfect now if I go back here let me try
to get the coupons
we execute that and perfect you can see
in the logs here in both the places in
the console window if that is open if
not we have the output window here we
have the log which is getting all
coupons
so that way you can see how dependency
injection is already built in with
minimal apis
if you are injecting something that is
not available you will of course have to
inject that where we have the ad
Services right here and it will
basically be before line 14 where you
are calling the Builder dot build
so where we have the Builder dot
Services you can register new services
and in the end point you can directly
get the implementation
so with that basic example of dependency
injection let's continue from the next
video
now let me run the project here and I
want to show you when we are posting
here
we do not want all of these properties
we only want name percent and is active
so in a typical API we do not expose the
complete object we only expose the dtos
for that endpoint
so for create we will add a dto in our
project
in models folder let me add a new folder
for dto
and in there I will add a new class
which will be coupon create
ETL
now there I only want three properties
so let me copy them and I will paste
those right here
we will go to our end point here and
when we are creating from body we will
only retrieve the coupon create dto
that way we are only getting what we
want
and I will call this coupon underscore C
underscore dto which is coupon create
dto
let me change the names here
we need the ID as well now in our coupon
create TTU we do not have the ID we can
remove this condition but where we have
to assign the ID we actually have to
convert this coupon create tto to coupon
dto
so if you want you can manually do that
coupon
is equal to new
and we can do the manual mapping like
that
once we do that we can add ID on this
coupon add that to our coupon store and
we are returning back the coupon
no rather than coupon here let me add a
new detail that we will call that as
coupon dto
the reason behind that is let's say we
never want to show when the coupon was
last updated
so in the coupon detail we will not have
that property and we will return back
the coupon dto so producers here will be
a coupon dto
except we will change that to coupon
create dto
and when we return back we will
basically have to convert this coupon to
the coupon dtl
so right here we will need the
conversion again
like that
and perfect that looks good we will
return back the coupon dtl
let me run the project and see that in
action
we go to our post here perfect now this
is different we only need few properties
here let me change those
and be execute
we take a look at the response perfect
updated is not present and that looks
good now create additional you can
change that if you want but I will skip
that for now
basically our dtos are functional and we
are not exposing our entity which is
coupon that is great news but having all
this conversion is super ugly I would
love if someone will already do that for
me and the answer for that is in next
video
mapping all of the object manually is
super painful thankfully there is
autumnapper
so for that we will have to install the
new kit package let me go there
in the browse tab we will search for
automapper
we will have to install the default
automaper package and we want to inject
Auto mapper with dependency injection so
we will install
automaper.extensions dot Microsoft top
dependency injection
perfect both of them are installed
now how can we Define the mapping
Auto mapper is smart if the property
names are same here it automatically
Maps them but we need to tell Auto
mapper that hey you should be mapping
coupon to coupon create tto or coupon
dto to coupon
that is something that we have to tell
Auto mapper
let me add a class file and we will
write that inside that class file I will
call that as mapping config
now if you want that configuration you
can do that in program.cs when we
register that to The Container but
rather than keeping everything clustered
in program.cs I like to separate it out
now that mapping is present inside the
profile that is inside automaper
once we add that here on the class file
in the Constructor we can call the
default methods that is create map
that create map is inside the profile
and there we have to tell the source and
destination
we want to map our coupon we will add
the using statement and we want to map
that to coupon create dto
now that will only map coupon to coupon
create tto but what if you want to map
coupon create detail to coupons
that is simple we just have reverse map
that and that will handle both the
scenario
I will copy this next I also want coupon
to coupon DTM
we will not be mapping coupon create tto
to coupon dto so that mapping is not
needed
perfect these two mapping look good
now we need to inject Auto mapper to
dependency injection
and that we will have to do before we
build the application
so right here I will say
builder.services.ad automaper and there
we will explicitly say type of mapping
config mapping config has all the
profiles for our Auto mapper that we
need
and with that it will do all the magic
of dependency injection and we can use
that right here in our post endpoint
if you remember when we have to inject
the logger here we were using eye logger
similarly we want the imapper let me
call that underscore mapper and we need
to add the using statement for Auto
mapper
that will automatically inject the
mapper based on the mapping profile that
we have
when we have to convert something we
will say coupon is equal to
and underscore mapper.map we want to map
this to a coupon and here we will say we
want to map this coupon create dto and
this will be the destination so it will
automatically map this coupon create TGO
to coupon and assign it right here
one line to replace all the mapping
pretty simple let me go back and here we
will say underscore mapper.map what is
the destination that is coupon dto
let's add that and what is something
that we are converting or the source
here that is coupon object
nothing else is needed perfect that
looks good
with that let me run the project and
make sure it still works
we will try to create something here
and great that is still functional and
everything is working as expected
if you have worked with the apis
with.net you know that where we have all
the models like right here we have the
coupon create dto we can add something
like required and we can add data
annotation
then if we go to program.cs right here
on the request we can check if the model
state is valid then proceed further
but with minimal apis model state
validators are not included by default
well at least not for now it might be in
future but that is not there in the
roadmap and the idea is to keep it
minimal so if you require validation you
can of course add your custom validation
like right here we have the bad request
and so on but if you want to use
something else like fluent API you can
also add that in your API project
in order to add that we will be adding
nougat package
so right here we will search for fluent
validation
we will be installing the fluent
validation dot dependency injection
extension
perfect that looks good and with that we
can add validations rather than
clustering everything I will be adding a
new folder here call that as validation
and we will be adding individual
validation
now validations might be different when
you are creating or when you are
updating a coupon
so let me add a class here which will be
coupon create validation
for fluent validations we will have the
Base Class of abstract validator we will
add the using statement and there it is
on generic so we need to Define what
this class will be validating and that
will be coupon create dtl
we can add the validation in Constructor
here and with fluent validation we use
rule 4 and there we Define what is the
validation we want
so first thing we do not want name to be
empty and the percent it must be between
1 and 100 percent
that is straightforward
how can we add that validation inside
our endpoint right here
well we need to inject the validator
right here similar to what we did with
imapper
so right here let me add I validator on
coupon create tto we will call that as
underscore validation
and before we check for the name here we
will say variable validation result is
equal to async and on the underscore
validation we have validate async inside
there we have to pass the coupon create
DTU
now we have an edit here because this is
an async method and we will have to
await
but the end point that we have here is
not async one workaround is to remove a
weight and right here we can call the
get
awaiter.getresult and that will work
that is completely okay let me show that
once we have the validation result here
we can check if the validation result
dot we have the is valid if that is not
valid we will return back an error
message
now edit messages are also inside the
validation result here so we can say
validation result dot errors DOT first
our default and we can convert that to a
string if there are any errors
so that looks good of course if you want
you can customize that rather than
returning first or default you can
return all the errors but again we are
keeping things super simple
perfect let me run this and show the
error message
when we run that we see a weird error
message failure to infer one or more
parameters and in the parameter Source
we have something called as unknown
well here it says did you mean to
register unknown parameter as a service
that basically means the dependency
injection that we added for validation
here we of course forgot to add that to
our container
so to add that we will say Builder dot
Services dot add validator from assembly
containing and here the class that we
are in is program class
that will register the validator service
and we can use that with dependency
injection
if we run that everything works and let
me try a post here
percent we will make it more than 100
and execute
we scroll down perfect we see the error
message percent must be between 1 and
100 you entered triple one zero
so our validation is working
but if we go down here
we are using the getawayter dot get
result let me continue and remove that
in the next video
now we are using the get
awaiter.getresult but what if we do not
want that we indeed want to await here
and we want to make our endpoint async
doing that is no big deal right before
the bracket here we can write async here
and that will make our endpoint an
asynchronous endpoint
so that was a super easy fix there
but now I have one question for you we
are injecting two things here I mapper I
validator and then this one we are
retrieving from body
if we go up where we have the integer ID
even if we don't Define anything here
let's say if we are saying that I logger
will be present here and then we have
the integer ID if we run that you will
notice it works
try that out and great that works so how
is the application determining on what
it is getting with dependency injection
what it is getting with parameters and
everything is confusing because we are
not saying that this eye logger is
actually being injected
what happens is the application will
first see for all the parameters that
hey is there a dependency injection
registered for this I logger or eye
mapper if it is then I will be injecting
that right here
for the other parameters like ID it
knows that it is expecting an ID here
but if it is a coupon create tto or
something else and it does not find any
dependency for that then it knows that
that will be provided as parameter
it does all of those pretty smart
mapping automatically and we do not have
to worry about that
so that is one thing that I wanted to
point out
with that let's continue from the next
video
now with the endpoints that we have like
let's say we have this coupon create dto
right here we are returning back a
coupon dto
and then when we have get here we are
returning a coupon or get all we are
returning an i enumerable of coupon
what I want to do is rather than
returning a different response based on
the type I want just one single response
type and that will of course have a data
along with that it will have other
properties like any error message
whether the request was successful what
was the status code and so on
so that way all of our endpoint will
have a standard response message
so in solution here in our models let me
add a new class
I will call that API response in there I
want few properties
first one will be a Boolean on if
everything was good so that will be a
success
then we want an object
which we will call as result and
anything that our API or endpoint
returns back like a coupon list or a
single coupon or the coupon that was
created all of that will be in this
wizard object
next I want the status code so that will
be of type HTTP status code and finally
I want all the error message
so list of string and we can call that
as error
messages
matter of fact that object looks good
here in the Constructor we will just say
error messages
is equal to new list of string
perfect looks good
so rather than returning anything else
here every time we will be returning the
API response
so at the top here we will have a new
API response and where we are returning
we need to store the result in response
dot result is equal to
we have the coupon store dot coupon list
here
and once we retrieve that we can say
response dot is success is true and
response touch status code is equal to
http status code dot ok
let me remove system.net here and add
that in a using statement
finally when we have result.okay we can
return back the response that looks good
this way we are standardizing what will
be the return type
that will be API response
let me copy these four lines and we have
the map get here let me work on that
we also need the API response I should
have copied that
and the result here is right here with
first.default we will paste that
and perfect that looks good for the get
individual coupon
then let me copy this again
where we have the post I will paste it
right here
and when we are actually creating we can
just set the is success to be false and
the status code to be HTTP status code
dotpad request
that way where we have the bad request
we do not have to assign both the flags
here
let me cut the result here everything
that is good will be at the end we will
paste it right there
but when something is not valid we need
to assign the error message
so we can say response dot we have the
error messages dot add
we will be adding the error message
right here cut that
paste it looks good
again you can be fancy rather than first
or default you can return all the error
message but you will have to do some
conversion
where we have resulted.bat request we
will return back the response
let me copy these two lines we will have
to add that right here
and
perfect looks good
now here rather than using fluent
validation sometimes you also need
server side validation that is why I
have added the custom error message and
returned back the response
we go down here where we have the
created add route we will return just
okay here because we have a standard
response
back response will have the coupon dto
so let me add that here and the status
code here you can of course say created
if you want and that looks good
we do not need this return statement we
will comment and let me cut and paste it
at the end where we have the other
created
with that the accepts here looks good
but the producers is API response
looks good
let me make sure everywhere we have that
it will be API response
great we have modified quite a few
things but now we have streamlined on
what will be the response for all the
endpoint it will only have our standard
API response that you can see
let me try to get here
and a success is true it returns them
status code 200 looks much better
let me try the post here
we will try an invalid percent
and perfect we have the error message
everything is much more organized with a
single type of API response
let me try to create and make sure that
works
make this a valid one
and we scroll down perfect is Success we
have the result that looks good
with that API response let me continue
from the next video
now that we have added the get endpoint
get all and post I want you to take an
assignment and implement the put and the
delete endpoints
one thing that you have to be careful is
with the put request if I go back for
create we have a coupon create tto
that we don't have an ID but when you
are updating you will require the ID
that needs to be updated
so for that you will have to create a
new dto call that coupon update dto and
Implement all of those endpoints that
are missing we already added them you
just need to implement these two
endpoints right here
so good luck with that assignment and I
will show you the solution in the next
video
I hope you were able to complete the
assignment
first thing we need to create a dto we
will copy and paste that and this will
be coupon update dto
the name here one property that I want
to add here is the ID
everything else looks good
perfect we need to work on map put here
let me go to the map post and copy what
we have
paste it right here
route is the same we will change that to
bitmap put here and we need Auto mapper
validator will be on coupon update dto
and from body we will receive a coupon
update dto
perfect
now that we have validation let me add
that as well copy and paste here
and we have coupon update video
let's add that
perfect now when we are updating we can
add one more validation that ID cannot
be empty and it has to be greater than
zero perfect validation looks good let
me go back to where we have the HTTP
post let me copy what we have here and
we will update
perfect copy that let me add some space
here that way I can easily read that
I think this is good enough
delete leave some space perfect
let's see what we are doing here
we have the API response looks good we
are validating let me call this
underscore U for update
perfect
we are validating the result here that
looks good let me scroll down
we have the logic what if coupon already
exist we will have to tweak that when we
are updating to make sure we don't get
the ID that we are already updating but
I will skip that for now
you can add some more validations here
if you want but I will keep things super
simple
after that in order to update we need to
retrieve that coupon
so basically we will retrieve that
coupon using first or default based on
the ID that we receive in the coupon
underscore U Dot dto
once we retrieve that then we can
manually update all the properties in
this coupon that we retrieved from the
coupon store based on the coupon udto
that we receive in parameter
we do not need any of these logic here
let me use Auto mapper
using automapper we will map tag to be
coupon dto and we want to convert the
coupon from store to coupon dto assign
that to the result status code here will
be okay and not created and perfect that
looks good
we also need to add the accepts here we
can give that a name so let me copy this
and right here I will paste that
name we can call that as update coupon
it accepts a coupon update dto
and producers will be 200 okay
great our update looks good let me run
and test that
if we try to get here we have one and
two let me try to update do right there
not post put
try that ID if we keep that as zero we
should see our validation
perfect ID must not be empty
we will keep that as 2 here
change the name and percent here to be
let me execute
we scroll down perfect it is successful
let me try the get all here
and great our update is working as
expected
we go back and we will update the delete
I will copy what I have within the
method here
paste it inside delete we only receive
the ID here
you can add a custom validator for
delete but we will keep things simple
and I will remove the validations right
here
when we are deleting we want to retrieve
that so we will retrieve that using
first our default
and here we can just check if coupon is
not now
then we will delete
and this will be coupon from store
in that case we will remove the coupon
from coupon store else we have an error
here so we can add the error message
invalid ID default successes false so we
can return back the response
for fact looks good if everything is
good in the if condition here we can
return back the success is true and
status code is okay
if you want you can also return no
content it depends on how you want to
implement but with delete typically we
return no content
perfect looks good
with that let me try delete in action
we get here we have the default one and
two
if we try to delete the ID3 we should
get error message invalid ID
let me try 2 here we get 200 okay
and execute that
our store now only has one coupon
so perfect with that update and delete
functionalities are working as expected